Everyone is talking about methylene blue because the HHS Secretary of Kennedy,
Robert F. Kennedy Jr. is taking it. Do you think there are any benefits to taking methylene blue?
I think there can be benefits to taking methylene blue.
But as you know, I'm not a fan of FAD things.
And this is one of those FAD things, I think. There's some data out there that methylene blue can be anti-inflammatory, especially to the brain.
There's some information out there that methylene blue can be beneficial for cancer patients.
You could probably find a lot of anecdotal information about methylene blue and cancer.
I don't think there's anything wrong with taking it in a situation that you're trying to deal with cancer and active cancer.
But typically the dosage of what people should be taking is just like a couple drops, maybe a couple times a day.
I've also seen these Instagram videos where people are opening their mouth and their mouth is totally blue because they're taking like a tablespoon of this stuff a day.
Because hey, if two drops are good for you, maybe a tablespoon must be that much better for you.
Remember, this isn't the nutritional supplement.
So by definition, the nutritional supplement is a food or an herb that God has created to either give us nutrition that we need like a vitamin or a mineral or to help heal something that's going on like an herb.
So, methylene blue doesn't fit into that category. It fits more into the category of fendizole and Ivermectin, which are drugs.
Remember, so you've asked this question in the past.
Should I, you know, my cancer is stable right now.
Should I just take Ivermectin on a regular basis or have had non-cancer patients ask or ask, cancer patients ask about family members.
Should they just be on Ivermectin just as a preventative?
And my answer is, no, I don't, I don't think so.
You don't still go on an antibiotic, antibiotics and save people's lives.
Can't argue that the discovery of antibiotics was a huge boom for mankind.
But doesn't mean I'm going to go on an antibiotic every day just because I don't want to get strapped.
It makes no sense. So, I don't think we're supposed to use things that would fall into the category of a drug as a preventative substance.
Yeah, if you had some weird disease out there that was going around that we saw maybe a few years ago, could methylene blue be helpful for that?
Yes, could, could Ivermectin, if I felt sick, be helpful for that?
In that case, yes, could Ivermectin and ventmenes all be extremely helpful for people that have cancer?
Yes, but remember it's yes on some people.
Yes, on everybody. It's not, they're not.
And none of these things are like, I'm going to take, you know, Ivermectin, that's going to cure everybody because I saw all these testimonials.
Well, what testimonials did you not see? The testimonials that it didn't work on somebody.
So, it's, you have to be careful with what you see out there.
Not everything is correct. And a lot of these influencers, quote unquote, they have no data behind them and supporting them.
No, they even have real anecdotal support of some of the things that they're sharing.
They're just trying to get clicks and they're just trying to get followers or just not saying that everything's bad out there.
But just be wise and be careful. And I think be prayerful.
You know, we're supposed to ask for wisdom.
So, when we pray, we're supposed to be asking for wisdom.
So, we're not supposed to be ignorant, okay?
The Apostle Paul says, 19 times in the New Testament, Brethren, I don't want you to be ignorant.
And I've shared this before, but I know he's talking about spiritual things, but it's about everything in life.
We can carry that through, that piece of wisdom through. We're not supposed to be ignorant.
So, not knocking the person, asking this question. So, please don't take it that way.
Just be careful about everything you see out there, and I'm not against Bethelene Blue.
But I'm against thinking that we should just jump at everything that we see. So, just be careful.